if mummies could talk what would they
tell us that's one of the questions at
the heart of Mike to--this research
artifacts like these offer unique
insight into the culture of ancient
Egypt middle class Egyptians would bury
their mummies with a mask that was made
out of papyrus layers just like my mom
would make a Halloween mask out of paper
mache using old newspaper they would use
old papyrus to make this mask now they
used ancient Greek to write on their
papyrus and in those you'll find
documents that give us a record of the
history of ancient Egypt because they're
layered and stuck together it's pretty
difficult to read the text without
damaging the mask and some
archaeologists have gone to extreme
lengths to pull them apart with the
destruction of these objects we're
losing insight into how they worshipped
into how they buried their dead and
their concept of the afterlife so Toth
is developing technologies to read the
text while preserving the masks the
trouble is that no two Mummy masks are
identical which means there's no single
way to image them
that's why Toth is working with
physicists archaeologists and even
ophthalmologists to test a range of
technologies our goal is to make all
these data freely available and also our
techniques for studying these objects
one promising approach is called phase
contrast imaging we witnessed a test run
at the Lawrence Berkeley Lab here's how
it works the scrap goes into an x-ray
chamber where it gets scanned as it
rotates then a team combs through the
scanned images looking for text
initially there were concerns that the
powerful x-rays could create tiny
distortions in the paper but so far that
hasn't been a problem we are trying to
offer non-destructive means by which one
can study the object itself and the
underlying text or artwork or cultural
heritage the
may not be seen by the human eye but
don't worry they won't be aiming any
x-rays at the mummies in your life